tu es un ami de nancy
d'orques ramon socias
seul
[Musique]
nous pensions que la bataille
était désormais derrière nous
aujourd'hui
la paix se profile
nous pensions que nos joies jamais ne
finiraient
nos pensions que notre lumière jamais ne
s'éteindrait lesieu
et petrov
[Musique]
galadriel pays de fine art in le moment
tant redouté
[Musique]
le mag ne dort jamais
ils patientent
dans les profondeurs la pénombre peut
tous nous engloutir sous la montagne
notre ennemi à bien des noms
tu as entendu parler de lui tu connais
le nom de sauron
si les mâles qui s'élèvent en terre du
milieu n'est pas maîtrisée il va se
répandre et tous nous avertir
trouver la lumière est jamais l'ombre ne
trouveras
ensemble nous pouvons gagner
combattez avec moi
chacun d'entre nous se doit de décider
quel chemin il devra emprunter
il ne peut y avoir de confiance entre un
art aurait une pierre
un beau jour là nous l'autre on viendra
se briser
vous à compter tant de mensonges
sur la terre du milieu